did you see rory and maul and what they
so they kind of talked about what's
going on in their podcast right and
uh maul was like
now [ __ ] that they they can they they
should be able to do that album like you
know what i'm saying and the one thing
that like they said and i know that
they're probably closer to
the situation than a lot of people are
right absolutely especially mom
[Music]
you guys weren't friends is what they
said them them guys ain't friends
they they were in a group together that
don't mean that they're friends
yeah i was friends with it was i it was
odd i was friends with joe uh joelle and
royce
you know what i'm saying royce was
friends with me and joe
you know i was saying
joelle was frizz with me and royce and
then some happened to that dynamic
between him and royce so it was just
like me and joelle was friends it was
just really really really odd man and
it's just it might be the oddest
concoction for an actual group that
toured together that put albums out
together in terms of like
how it was formed right there was really
no you guys never had a real origin
story it's not like you guys grew up
together
we think of griselda we think of wu-tang
all these people grew up together so
you know the
downfalls of those groups were it was a
lot of emotional family based [ __ ] with
you guys it was
listen man the fans wanted this we did
it